vizekanzler bald superminister
wirtschaft klima herbig mit welchen
superkräften können und wollen sie sich
corona widmen
das ist richtig großem vorsprung gesagt
wurde
wir werden die regierung antreten in
einer zeit die die schwerste
gesundheitskrise in deutschland ist und
die sich auftürmende vierte welle ist
bedrohlich als alle wellen davor und die
waren ja schon schlimm genug und die
maßnahmen die politisch ergriffen worden
waren rabiat
wir haben jetzt eine andere situation
wir können differenzierte maßnahmen
anwenden das leistet das
infektionsschutzgesetz aber sie müssen
eben auch zu einem erfolg führen und die
zeit wird knapp also die dass die zahlen
sind ja inzwischen denkt an hat geläufig
ja aber auch geläufig wir verdoppeln die
infektionsrate alle zwölf tage die kurve
gibt so nach oben
0,8 prozent von allen infizierten landen
auf der intensivstation die
krankenhäuser sind jetzt schon voll da
muss man jetzt nicht besonders gut im
kopfrechnen sein um zu sagen das geht es
um tage die tage allerdings können
genutzt werden die maßnahmen die wir
bereit gestellt haben sind noch in ihren
augen das werden gesehen aber sie sind
differenzierte maßnahmen so dass man
tatsächlich
differenziert vorgehen kann und dann
muss man das aber auch tun wenn es nicht
gelingt dann bleiben nur noch pauschale
maßnahmen und dann haben wir das tool
die toolbox wie die den werkzeugkasten
demir bereitgestellt haben nicht gut
genug genutzt er kann aber gut genutzt
werden alle experten haben gesagt wenn
das konsequent angewandt wird dann kann
die vierte werde gebrochen werden dann
kann man muss man sehen wie weit hier
untergeht dann auch eine hohe
nato ist zu hoch würdigen für die
infektions für die für die krankenhäuser
für die
intensivstation aber das ist ja nun
offensichtlich jetzt nicht der fall
können sie vielleicht verraten was die
bundeskanzlerin am dienstag von ihnen
wollte und ist es richtig dass sie
tatsächlich über einen locker und mit
ihnen gesprochen das könnte ich vorhaben
das werde ich auch nicht tun weil es ein
vertrauens raum der politik gibt und
zudem gehören die gespräche mit der
bundeskanzlerin der muss bewahrt bleiben
aber unabhängig von dem gespräch ist
doch völlig klar entweder gegen die
zahlen jetzt runter darauf setzen wir
und
dafür haben wir die mittel
bereitgestellt ja und wenn es nicht geht
dann wird man über andere reden müssen
ich hoffe aber dass wir uns selber alle
die ganze gesellschaft nicht nötig das
ist ja keine frage der von der nächsten
bundesregierung sondern alle menschen
müssen ihren beitrag leisten und dann
können wir als gesellschaft schlimmeres
verhindern ihr zukünftiger ampel
koalitionspartner sitzt in links rechts
neben ihnen je nachdem von wo man guckt
volker wissing sie haben mitverhandelt
mitgeführt zukünftige verkehrsminister
werden olaf scholz und sie dieses
frische
infektionsschutzgesetz vor diesen 10 12
bereits verändern müssen und verschärfen
müssen zunächst einmal ist diese
pandemie sehr ernst zu nehmen die
entwicklung die wir sehen ist
schockierend wir brauchen ein
entschlossenes handeln auch der
bundesländer das was wir in dem
gemeinsamen verabschiedeten
infektionsschutzgesetz dem auch alle 16
länder zugestimmt haben an maßnahmen
vorgesehen haben ist noch nicht
ausgeschöpft das heißt es gibt noch eine
ganze reihe von möglichkeiten glauben
kann nein ich halte es für erforderlich
dass wir nicht ständig neue maßnahmen
vom gesetzgeber fordern sondern es
einmal das nutzen was auf dem tisch
liegt das geht am schnellsten das geht
so fort ich halte kontakt beschränkungen
für dringend erforderlich ich glaube
dass wir diese situation gar nicht ernst
genug nehmen können ich glaube aber auch
dass mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz der
staat handlungsfähig ist interessant für
enrique rosbach ist bei uns von der
süddeutschen zeitung hauptstadtbüro
parlamentsdirektion parlament zur
redaktion der süddeutschen zeitung zehn
tage will sich die ampel jetzt noch
geben um zu prüfen ob das erste besteck
dieses infektionsschutzgesetzes
tatsächlich ausreicht glauben sie es
reicht
ich fürchte dass es nicht reichen wird
ich fürchte allerdings vor allem das
zehn tage gucken wir mal keine besonders
gute idee ist weil wir gerade gehört wie
in welchem zeitdruck muss sich die
infektionszahlen verdoppeln und das
problem ist einfach die zeit ist jetzt
einfach schon abgelaufen das ist
natürlich war die bundesländer hätten
schon sehr viel früher sehr viel
einschneidendere massnahmen erlassen
können bis hin zur flächendeckenden
lockt bei uns ist hätte ja die alte
rechtslage und auch die neue jahr für
eine gewisse zeit noch zugelassen haben
sie nicht gemacht gleichzeitig hatte man
schon auch den eindruck dass die neue
regierung doch erst mal so ein bisschen
gucken wollte und natürlich auch nur
begrenzt handlungsfähig ist dabei dem
virus ist es nun mal leider egal ob man
sich jetzt in so einer interims phase
zwischen zwei regierungen befindet wo
die frühere regierungspartei sich
sortiert und die neuen sich auch
irgendwie sortieren und reduzieren ist
noch freundlich formuliert wir begrüßen
christiane hoffmann journalistin vom
spiegel wird es einen moment geben frau
hoffmann was denken sie wie damals
merkel und steinbrück in der finanzkrise
wo ein kanzler olaf scholz und ein
vizekanzler robert habeck in einer rede
an die nation neue maßnahmen für können
ich würde das auf keinen fall für
ausgeschlossen halten
es ist wie frau rosbach gesagt hat jetzt
noch mal zehn tage abzuwarten während
die zahlen sich so entwickeln wie hier
habe ich das eben
skizziert hat das erscheint dafür gibt
sich keine plausible lied warum man das
tun sollte es müsse jetzt gehandelt
werden und es hätte im grunde schon
lange gehandelt werden müssen ich finde
es natürlich richtig dass man in die
zukunft hinein spricht aber wenn ich mir
überlege was wird das für eine regierung
werden dieser ampel muss ich mich auch
fragen wie konnten wir überhaupt in
diese pandemie lage jetzt hinein kommen
wie konnte das passieren dass
deutschland mit den mit der erfahrung
die es jetzt in der pandemie schon
gemacht hat in dieser lage gelandet ist
in der das ausland kopfschüttelnd auf
uns kommt und sagt wie kann das
eigentlich sein und ich habe
befürchtungen dass dieses versagen was
wir hier sehen kein gutes zeichen ist
für die künftige regierung ich sehe
schon das ist eine übergangszeit das ist
eine schwierige zeit aber mir erschließt
sich nicht warum es nicht möglich
gewesen wäre viel früher klarer zu
erkennen welche situationen wie hier
kommen und maßnahmen zu erlassen und
nicht genau in die falsche richtung zu
steuern und die pandemische lage
abzuschaffen die alte regierung hört
nicht gut auf und die neue regierung
fängt nicht gut an
zerschmetterte gewissheiten
es könnte ein unangenehmer winter werden
wie jetzt schon bei unseren nachbarn in
den niederlanden
déjà vu beim boostern fehler verzeihen
ist das eine
aus fehlern nichts lernen die
spezialität des jens spahn entscheidend
ist dass sich unser biontech lager so
schnell leert kommunikation am
wochenende war desaströs
fatal auch die selbstzufriedenheit bei
der künftigen regierung also man kann
sagen die ampel funktioniert auch bevor
es gibt wohl eher ampelausfall
epidemische lage beendet durcheinander
vergrößert vorgestern eingestellt ins
kanzleramt zum nachsitzen fazit und es
darf niemals jemand gegen der sagt
irgendwas geht nicht wenn es notwendig
ist muss es getan werden soll wohl
heißen
flächendeckende corona maßnahmen aber
bitte erst nach einer gesichtswahrenden
karenzzeit
auch beim impfen ein riesen
scherbenhaufen im flug schleppendes
boostern impfpflicht für das
pflegepersonal oder gar für alle
wir halten es einfach für erforderlich
weil wir sonst aus dieser pandemie
einfach nicht rauskommen
verlorene glaubwürdigkeit der politik
besonders schlimm trifft es die fdp da
wäre in den letzten wochen weniger wohl
mehr gewesen
dass das alte maßnahmenpaket nicht so
bleiben konnte wie es wahr ist eine
frage der wahrhaftigkeit
wahrhaft summiert sich das
politikversagen stand heute auf 75
1961 neuinfektionen an einem tag
norbert röttgen ist bei uns von der cdu
kandidiert neuerlich für den vorsitz der
cdu herr röttgen fangen wir vielleicht
mal bei ihrem gesundheitsminister an was
hindert sich entspannen eigentlich daran
eine gute arbeit zu leisten und immer
noch zu leisten ich für dieses land als
gesundheitsminister also er hat gute
arbeit geleistet aber hat auch fehler
gemacht er hat 21 10 uhr noch gesagt
dass vier von fünf leute geimpft sind
und dass wir diese epidemische notlage
auf lesen kann hat auch fehler gemacht
und ich glaube dass wenn man diesen
bericht sich wirklich
vergegenwärtigt dann wird deutlich dass
sowohl die gegenwärtige regierung
versäumnisse zu verantworten hat als
auch die ins amt kommende regierung
schon bevor sie ins amt gekommen ist
sich vergaloppiert hat und jetzt aus
diesem fall galoppieren nicht mehr so
richtig raus kommt er nochmal bei und
der alten großen koalition was hat frau
merkel gehindert diese gute managerin
der korona krise zu bleiben die sie war
warum hat sie sich im wahlkampf nicht zu
wort gemeldet warum hatten wir lange
monate das gefühl dass es ihr einfach
nicht so richtig ist und plötzlich ist
er wieder da also also es ist jedenfalls
so ich war in keiner exekutiven
verantwortung aber ich sage und stehe
auch nicht an zu beschönigen dass wir
auch deshalb sind wo wir sind weil
maßnahmen die rechtlich möglich gewesen
sind und immer noch möglich sind nicht
getroffen worden sind das ist jetzt die
lage ich bin jetzt hier nicht ich habe
kein mandat irgendwelche schuld fragen
zu klären das hilft ja im moment auch
gar nicht sondern ich glaube das was wir
jetzt
zur kenntnis nehmen müssen ist dass die
lage dramatisch ist das ist die
dramatischste die gefährlichste die
schädlichste ist die wir je in der
ganzen panini hatten und noch mal ich
glaube dass beide teile die aus dem amt
scheidende regierung in ihren
möglichkeiten bislang sie ist ja immer
noch die regierung und die ins amt
kommende regierung in dieser situation
fehler gemacht haben
selbst manchmal also aus dieses bei uns
ist dass wir im bundesrat aber auf der
anderen seite wenn es so ist wie sie
sagen keine zustimmung erlebt haben
durch alle ministerpräsidenten auch
durch die schwarzen zu diesem neuen dass
er nur vor sie wollen mich immer auf den
punkt sozusagen festhalten der sich
hierzu rückblick und erkläre warum sind
wir jetzt in dieser lage geraten ich
glaube dass ja das aber ich sage nochmal
sind versäumnisse und sind versäumnisse
der regierung sonst wären wir ja nicht
da wo wir sind weil die rechtlichen
möglichkeiten da waren so es hat auch
kommunikationsfehler gegeben als hat vor
allen dingen entscheidungs defizite
gegeben und es hat auf der anderen seite
voreilige falsche festlegungen
verkündungen der neuen koalitionäre
gegeben und ich will jetzt nur auch
einmal versuchen zu fragen was ist denn
jetzt die konsequenz für jetzt daraus
das finde ich ist ja das entscheidende
wenn die lage so dramatisch ist und wenn
wir sagen müssen wir haben fünf nach
zwölf und ihre zahlen für die man die
man auch prognostizieren kann für die
zukunft was sie heute bedeuten was sie
haben eben erklärt was 75.000
neuinfektionen bedeuten in zwei wochen
für die intensivbetten belegen das
wissen wir heute
darum versuche ich auch dieses gespräch
zu nutzen um darauf dafür zu appellieren
dass das jetzt eine verantwortung von
beiden ist der alten regierung und der
neuen regierung sind jetzt noch in der
situation zu handeln wie haben sie denn
dass das ein moment es wo die
bundeskanzlerin diese regierung ermahnen
müsste über einen zehntägigen 14-tägigen
locker und nachzudenken man sich
gemeinsam vor die presse zu stellen mit
roll abschalt ja das ist also das ist
man das würde ich für richtig halten ich
fänd ich finde wir können jetzt sitzen
wir sind ja bald opposition und das
worauf man alles analysiert das ist eine
gigantische potenzielle hypothek für
eine regierung die noch gar nicht im amt
ist die sie sich selber eingehandelt hat
ich finde die lage ist zu ernst als dass
wir jetzt sagen wir sind opposition und
wacht man auf die fehler bis sie sich
voll entfalten sondern die lage ist so
ernst sie ist es so dramatisch es geht
um tote und um viele tote und um
dramatische situation in unserem land
die dramatische die wir je in unserer
geschichte hatten die ist jetzt nicht
nur dieser pandemie sohn überhaupt und
darum glaube ich wäre es ein zeichen von
überparteilichkeit nicht von streit
führung wenn die
noch kanzlerin und der neue kanzler vor
die bürgerinnen und bürger treten und
sie und und eine ansprache halten und
sich direkt an die bürger wenden wenn
man zusammenkommt und fragt was was wir
alle wissen das ist nicht verantwortbar
ist zehn tage zu warten das ist die
unmittelbare konsequenz aus dem was sie
gesagt haben wir haben keine zeit mehr
zu warten weil in zehn tagen haben wir
zehn mal 75.000 neuinfektionen also
jetzt zusammen zu kommen überparteilich
und zu vereinbaren was die nötigen
handlungsschritte sind aber sie wissen
dass ein mir schleswig-holstein
beispielsweise bremen dass niedersachsen
sehr zurückhaltend sind zu sagen wir
haben jetzt eine gesamtdeutsche notlage
die möchten auch nicht sofort etwas ja
aber das ist zum reduzierten gehören
ändern ja also wir hatten schon die
handlungsmöglichkeiten bleiben natürlich
differenziert je nach lage wir haben
aber die entwicklung dass sich das ganze
geschehen ja von süd osteuropa rumänien
nach westen und norden entwickelt das
heißt das ist eine wanderungsbewegung
dieses virus die auch bald in nordeuropa
angekommen sein wird also das steht
alles wir wissen was passiert wenn
wissen s wirklich was passiert und darum
wissen wir auch was jetzt zu tun ist
nämlich kontakt beschränkungen sind
unabweisbar und sie müssen dort erfolgen
wo die lage ist und darum muss man
darüber reden ob instrumente die jetzt
nicht mehr vorhanden sind ich will das
jetzt will er auf die kritik verzichten
dass sie wieder da sein müssen weil sie
nötig sein könnten und ich appelliere
wirklich daran dass wir jetzt nicht
dieses diese dieses diese katastrophe im
modus von regierung und opposition
verhandeln sondern ich appelliere daran
ich bin an sich immer sehr für regierung
opposition die auseinandersetzung aber
es ist so ernst dass das eine lage ist
für überparteiliche verantwortung und
ausgedrückt in der alten und in der
neuen regierung dass man wirklich appell
das zu tun und es nicht in den
kategorien regierung versus opposition
zu machen derzeit zu überlassen das
klingt jetzt ganz anders als sie gerade
gesagt haben und auch als sie gesehen
haben herr wissen würden sie darüber
nochmal nachdenken
wollen sagen können wer jetzt
tatsächlich gestern noch vom freedom day
geredet haben und jetzt sagen es ist
fünf nach zwölf und wir gucken mal ob
unsere maßnahmen eigentlich reichen und
wir lassen uns noch zehn tage zeit oder
tun wir das lieber nicht
ich halte nichts von abwarten die lage
ist ziemlich klar und sie ist sehr
konkret und ich weiß auch nicht was das
für eine diskussion sein soll ich hätte
es lieber konkrete und zwar sofort
handeln auf der grundlage des
infektionsschutzgesetzes die maßnahmen
die dort angeordnet sind ausschöpfen
nicht alle hatten nicht die sortieren
lassen
sie haben ihre sichtbare legt er ich
halte nichts davon jetzt zu sagen wir
warten ab sondern ich halte viel davon
morgen sollten die länder die
notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen die das
infektionsschutzgesetz hergibt kontakt
beschränkungen in den verschärfungen
verbot von großen veranstaltungen das
ist ja möglich dazu müssen wir nicht
abwarten oder irgendein gesetz ändern
das kann sofort geschehen das kann
allerdings nicht die künftige regierung
tun die noch nicht im amt ist und keine
exekutive gewalt hat das kann erst
passieren wenn sie ins amt geraten ist
oder ins amt gewählt im ins amt kommt
ein antworten ist aber die länder können
das sofort tun und die länder halten die
regelung ja auch für richtig sonst
hätten sie dem infektionsschutzgesetz
nicht zugestimmt und deswegen muss
sofort gehandelt werden und
selbstverständlich muss der deutsche
bundestag jederzeit handlungsfähig seien
das infektionsschutzgesetz wenn bedarf
besteht auch nach zu schärfen
gegenwärtig haben wir diese erbärmlichen
ja aber gegenwärtig müssen wir doch
sagen
die maßnahmen die dort morgen ergriffen
werden können müssen doch erst einmal
ausgeschöpft werden ich kann doch nicht
sagen ich habe eine
infektionsschutzgesetz ich kann mir
kontakt beschränkungen das land anordnen
tue das nicht fordere aber den
gesetzgeber auf noch mehr maßnahmen
anzuordnen schöpfen wir doch jetzt mal
aus was geht das können wir morgen schon
zu war auf ihren rücken ganz schnell
noch mal was am 8.11 herr buschmann
gesagt hat der zukünftige justizminister
dieser regierung auch am 25 november
werden die einschneidenden tiefen
grundrechtseingriffe die uns besorgt
haben auch schon außer kraft gesetzt
wird ab dem 25
november wenn es nach unserem konzept
geht keine lockdown es keine
betriebsschließung geben und dieser
dinge keine ausgangssperren und so
weiter das heißt auch am 25 november hat
man schon einen kleinen freedom day am
27 es ist nahezu exakt einen monat her
wie kann man so also sie haben ja auch
dann eine lernkurve diaz exponentiell
wir haben natürlich auch ich sage ihnen
ganz ehrlich wir haben uns natürlich
auch auf das verlassen was die
bundesregierung gesagt hat sie haben
vorhin den bundesgesundheitsminister
zitiert der gesagt hat die epidemische
notlage kann auslaufen was erwartet man
von einer liberalen partei die ein
bundesgesundheitsminister der täglich
das infektionsgeschehen beobachtet und
öffentlich sagt die epidemische notlage
kann aus lauschen ein bisschen länger
her dass gesagt änderung 24 zehnter
24 zehnter und und dann was mich auch
was mich ehrlich gesagt immer gewundert
hat ist dass die bundesregierung von dem
man ja auch davon ausgehen kann dass sie
über tiefere einblicke verfügt also das
parlament dass die bundesregierung die
bürger tests abgeschafft hat vom winter
und ich habe immer gesagt das ist ein
fehler warum macht man jetzt die bürger
test kostenpflichtig mit der folge dass
man nicht mehr so viele informationen
über das infektionsgeschehen sagen die
die bundesregierung lasse ich den
gedanken zu ende führen auch die
bundeskanzlerin hielt das für richtig
sonst hat das ist ja nicht unterstützt
und ich frage mich warum hat man das
gemacht offensichtlich gab es auch bei
der bundesregierung eine gravierende
fehleinschätzung über das was uns in
diesem winter bevorsteht sein und
deswegen gibt es keinen grund dass die
parteien gegenseitig mit dem finger
aufeinander zeigen sondern ich mag die
srg hat den auftrag zum handeln alles
was sie gesagt haben und die verkündung
des freedom day sagt ja auch eine
oppositionszeit der sp fdp gegeben wo
sie die korona politik immer kritisiert
wenn das alles beruhte wenn das beruhte
auf der fehleinschätzung der
bundesregierung die die grundlage ihrer
ankündigung waren dann muss man doch
jetzt sagen wir sind jetzt alle zu einer
besseren einschätzung der lage gekommen
richtig handeln also würde ich sagen
wenn wir jetzt zu einer besseren
einschätzung der lage gekommen sind dann
sollten wir doch lage adäquat handeln
einverstanden und wir stimmen darin
überein wie herr buschmann korrekt
dargestellt hat das mit der neuesten
gesetzgebung maßnahmen ab die
möglichkeit von maßnahmen abgeschafft
worden sind das ist ja das ist ja die
ist ja des gesetzes das beschlossen
wichtig so und wenn das so ist dass man
das man auf die lage verschärfen die sie
nicht richtig gesehen haben reagiert hat
weil man noch eine andere lage
einschätzung hatte mit einer
entschärfung mit einer reduzierung der
möglichkeiten und montageprozesse jetzt
schon wieder nach geschaffter es wurde
nachgeschärft das stimmt aber man ist es
immer noch ich habe noch gewisse dabei
schließen sich anderen dingen sie können
also im grunde sind breitflächig immer
noch die möglichkeiten der kontakt
untersagung den ländern jetzt verboten
so und wenn wir alle zur erkenntnis
kommen dass das jetzt das nötige ist die
welle zu brechen kontakte zu
unterbrechen dann kann man glaube ich
nein und das ist dann nicht mehr nach
der neuen gesetzeslage sobald sie greift
nicht mehr möglich die länder können
dann das nicht mehr machen was sie jetzt
können das ist ja der sinn ihres
gesetzes
was man jetzt sagen kann sie hat die sie
vorher nicht konnten es gibt jetzt 3g am
arbeitsplatz ist hätte man im sommer in
führung sabra aber die regierung dagegen
es gibt jetzt zwar immer noch nicht weil
die fdp erst noch expertenanhörung
abhalten muss aber irgendwann soll es
eine impfpflicht für an bestimmte
einrichtungen geben da war die regierung
auch dagegen
die spd ja ich verstehe ich dass sie
nicht sagen wollen was du sonst ja
12 antworten vor ich glaube sechs oder
acht wochen noch nicht mal dass der
arbeitgeber erfragen darauf ob jemand
geimpft ist
nämlich dass
ab einer bestimmten incident
nicht das gab es vorher nicht die
möglichkeit tatsächlich es ist untersagt
gewesen schulen zu schließen und das
kann man jetzt nach dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz kann man das
nicht vorher konnten schulen geschlossen
werden jedoch differenziert aber
differenziert wir gehen hier habe ich
mal einen schritt weiter und sagen olaf
scholz hat gesagt man kann führung von
mir haben wenn man möchte hätten sie ein
bisschen eher um führung bitten müssen
durch den bundeskanzler den man in
dieser phase ja auch schwer vermisst
wir haben es gerade gehört wir sind in
einer politischen übergangsphase das ist
für die kommende regierung nicht leicht
weil sie ja den apparat nicht hat auf
der wissensgrundlage die dir einen
apparat zur verfügung stellt die
richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen von
der scheidenden regierung muss man
allerdings erwarten die kriege jedoch
geld da für diese müssen wir arbeiten
trotzdem gibt es eine ein problem die
scheidende regierung hat keine mehrheit
mehr im parlament ist sonst wäre sie ja
nicht mehr die scheidende regierung und
das muss irgendwie zusammen kommen das
geht auch wenn der normalzustand des
politischen betriebs irgendwie so vor
sich hin plätschert in der situation hat
es das virus leicht das muss man sagen
und dazu kommt doch ist es so natürlich
wir sind alle sind noch damit
beschäftigt ich habe mein kommen das
ministerium noch nicht einmal von innen
gesehen und wenn ich jetzt für die
extreme den gast auf der bekommen leider
fehlt es einmal kurz versuchte zu
erklären wenn wir gemeinsam zusammen
arbeiten wollen müssen wir glaube ich
eine nein-stimme logischen schritt
weiter gehen aber es ist nicht leicht
die expertise des apparates der den
unterschied zwischen regierung und
opposition ausmacht schon vollumfänglich
zu nutzen
trotzdem gibt es ein problem dass
vielleicht erklärt warum wir immer so
doof aussehen alle und alle parteien
alle regierungen wenn wir alles was wir
immer wissen richtig machen würden
sowohl politisch richtig entscheiden
würden wie menschen die richtig regieren
würden dann hätten wir diese vierte
welle nicht das infektionsschutzgesetz
gibt wenn sie alle angewandt werden
genug möglichkeiten die vierte welle zu
brechen sie werden aber nicht alle
angewandt oder zu spät die erkenntnisse
von impfen oder von dem aufhalten bett
ist sind darin die waren ja die waren
den schlimmen waren alle da trotzdem
wieder zurück
das ist ja ich komme jetzt gleich zudem
so woran liegt es ich glaube an
menschlichen mangeln wir sind träge wir
sind träge gewesen und wir holen darauf
hoffen dass das was im alltag gut
funktioniert nächsten alltag morgen und
übermorgen auch so ist und politiker
sind letztlich auch menschen und die
überbringer der schlechten botschaften
heute geht es gut aber in 14 tagen
könnte schon ganz anders sein dass das
wird nicht mit erfüllen gelogen
es habe ja nein deswegen ist legen frau
baerbock lassen sie nicht ganz raus ich
bin doch jetzt gleich bei der brücke zu
allen hier wir kriegen den bringen wir
soziale maßnahmen ergreifen also
lockdown dann heißt das dass wir nicht
in der lage waren mit vorausschauen und
differenzierten maßnahmen zu bestehen
das sind aber natürlich nicht triviale
maßnahmen schulschließung sagen welche
schulen dicht erinnern sich alle anders
not und elend dienen die kinder
ausgesetzt waren kontakt massen haben
heißt dann dass menschen sich nicht
besuchen können erstmal wahrscheinlich
unbedingt geimpft aber auch geimpfte die
die existenznöte von kunst kultur
schaffen den restaurantbetreibern die
sind ja ernst zu nehmen das heißt wir
sind eigentlich dazu verpflichtet immer
das mildere mittel zu nehmen
freiheit zu nehmen das sind ja einer
offenen gesellschaft schuldig das ist
der grund warum die ampel regierung
gesagt hat setzen wir einmal noch darauf
dass wir in der lage sind unseren
inneren schweinehund die innere trägheit
zu überwinden und schauen auf die
maßnahmen die wir haben dir garantiert
reinzugehen tablette und wenn es nicht
klappt muss man ja sagen die dramatik
ist ja da man hat dann sind wir selber
schuld und dann müssen wir mit dem
großen vorschlaghammer draufhaben haben
wieder alles dichtmachen wir haben aber
noch eine restchance von wenigen tagen
ja weil es ist doch unlogisch ruin in
letzter zeit
frau hofmann geht auch aus dem sack und
ich lasse es lieber sie sagen frau darf
man es geht doch nicht um innere
trägheit politische führung bedeutet
dass man eine situation die man erkannt
hat adäquat einschätzt und dann auch
unangenehme wahrheiten ausspricht und
die entsprechenden maßnahmen ergreift
das man
die bevölkerung die bürgerinnen und
bürger davon überzeugt was nötig ist
wenn man zu der erkenntnis gekommen ist
was nötig ist und nicht die augen
verschließt die definition von
politischer führung und wenn sie sagen
wir konnten es nicht wissen weil wir
nicht das expertenwissen hatten oder
keinen apparat hatten dass das überzeugt
nicht im geringsten es gab ausreichend
experten die ihnen gerne und ständig
rede und antwort gestanden hätten die
sich den mund fusselig geredet hatten
und sich schon vorkam wie idioten weil
sich also mal wieder gesagt hat was wir
gesagt haben was passieren wird also
jetzt im nachhinein zu sagen wir wir
wussten es nicht also ich bin mich
schockiert dass auch als als bürgerin
dass das muss ich wirklich sagen also
natürlich konnte man das wissen und
natürlich hätte es auch politischer
führung der neuen regierung bedurft sie
war in einer schwierigen situation weil
sie noch nicht die exekutiv macht ist
aber was hat herrn scholz daran
gehindert sich hinzustellen und zu sagen
achtung wir laufen hier in eine ganz
schwierige situation
und dafür zu kämpfen mit seiner
parlamentsmehrheit dass die massnahmen
verschärft werden so ich frage jetzt
nicht noch mal nach olaf scholz und die
führung gestellt haben es verstanden
werden du hast als opposition keinen
einblick in die vorhaltung der impfdosen
du weißt nicht wie die verteilung ist
das ist alles länger
regieren entscheidend war doch in der
regierung kein oppositions politiker der
welt das ist recht stolz sein kann wenn
sich der gesundheitsminister hinstellt
und sagen jetzt alle boostern
voraussehen das ist gar nicht möglich
ist weil der impfstoff nicht da ist das
ist echt das ist exekutives handeln
darauf wie sich hin natürlich darf man
haben sie recht alle hätten wissen
können wie eine impfrate von knapp 70
oder um die 70 prozent ich aber einer
der inseln variante im winter wird das
und dass das ist das noch mal zu geben
das ist ein schandfleck der deutschen
politik dass wir da so rein gelaufen
sind so von diesem bereich jahr sollte
es aber sich sagen wollte ist warum ist
das passiert da sind wir alles keine
vollidioten die politiker machen ja
nicht mit absicht fehler sondern es gibt
das ewige zögern auf den ländern auf der
ebene der länder die gleichen
ministerpräsidenten die drei tage später
gesagt hat wir sind jetzt zum lockdown
kommen und bloß nicht die epidemische
lage auslaufen lassen haben wir in ihrem
bundesland fröhlich ist karneval feiern
erlaubt die leute lagen sich besoffen in
den arm und haben sich abgeknutscht und
drei tage später hat man gesagt wir
müssen jetzt wieder die kontakte
reduzieren dass man kriegt das nicht
logisch zusammen man kriegt es nur
zusammen wenn man sieht dass
das man immer das schlimmste nicht sehen
will sondern jetzt und jetzt ist jetzt
auch die letzte chance
es ist die letzte chance ist jetzt zu
sehen die maßnahmen die in den
infektionsschutz gesetzten sind
anzuhalten und wenn wir jetzt ja doch
hätten sie sind ja da sie sind ja auch
einen neuen
ersten haft sind sind nicht
vollumfänglich an wie man radio warum
die steigerung waren es ihm nicht
vollumfänglich angewandt es ist nur zu
erklären in dem das gleiche was ich
versucht habe zu erklären ist die
erkenntnis du dir alle gucken oettinger
heute abend ich würde mich wundern wenn
der ganze katalog morgen in allen
bundesländern in polen für mich da ist
offenbar so offen bleiben dieser laden
sie sind jetzt regierung will frau
hoffmann wahrscheinlich sagen alle wenig
gewählte politiker sie sind dafür
gewählt dass sie nicht träge sind und
nicht ständig zögern das ist die
definition von politik man kann doch
nicht jetzt versuchen das so weg zu
analysieren und zu sagen menschen wollen
nie das schlimmste sehen wir haben sie
deshalb gewählt damit sie dahin gucken
wie die real uns eine präventive politik
machen das bieten sie jetzt sogar
anfassbar es ist angekündigt das ist ein
expertengremium geben soll und das ist
ein krisenstab geben soll welche was
müsste dieser krisenstab jetzt
klugerweise tun in ihren augen was ist
wichtig also der krisenstab muss vor
allem dafür sorgen dass ein
reibungsloser als zusammenarbeiten von
bund und ländern funktioniert also die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die hat ja
jetzt nicht wirklich immer die besten
aller denkbaren lösungen hervorgebracht
und ist als gremium für so
einschneidende maßnahmen ja eigentlich
auch nicht gedacht immer und befugt
gewesen und das problem in das wir jetzt
reinlaufen das hat herr harbecke richtig
beschrieben die länder hätten bestimmte
dinge tun können haben sie aber nicht
getan haben nach einheitlichkeit und
nach dem bund gucken
einfacher ist klar wenn man nicht nur
als bayerischer ministerpräsident
in london für ungeimpfte verhängt
sondern wenn das die kollegen in
schleswig holstein auch mitmachen weil
dann ist man nicht der einzige der das
machen muss das verstehe ich schon aber
sinnvoll ist es natürlich nicht unserem
krisenstab muss natürlich dafür sorgen
dass informationen über wie viel
impfstoff ist da wo kommt er her wie
können wir die booster impfung
organisieren sind die impfzentren
wirklich in standby wie sie vereinbart
war oder sind die jetzt einfach doch zu
und die leute stehen vier stunden also
ja beides so und eben jetzt endlich auch
den herrn wirken auch ohne verzahnen de
kommunikation absprache mit den ländern
die nicht sich auf wir treffen uns
umsetzen bis nachts um vier zusammen und
denken uns eine oster ruhe aus und
danach gehen wir auseinander und sagen
in jede dritte kamera was anderes das
kann natürlich nicht sein und das müsste
so ein krisenstab lösen und das
expertengremium finde ich im prinzip
auch gut ich fand es ein großes defizit
der aktuell jetzt noch im amt sich
befinden bundesregierung dass das doch
relativ intransparent war wer hat er
beraten und das war zum beispiel auch so
ich glaube nicht dass ein einziges mal
zum beispiel ein kinderarzt und ein
kinderpsychologe zu mir weil zu dem
gremium gehört hat ja und das finde ich
schon wichtig dass eben diese bisschen
ganzheitliche betrachtung mit dabei ist
sich fragt bevor die politik wieder dran
ist frau hoffmann nochmal christian
hoffmann wir hatten in der letzten woche
giovanni di lorenzo hier zu sitzen der
von italien erzählte und nicht nur von
mario draghi denen sie in die disco
nennen den deutschen weil er eine
perfekte impfkampagne organisiert hat in
italien mit 90 prozent importe das hat
er nicht höchstselbst getan sondern
durch einen alten gebirgsjäger einen
general der immer mit diesem hübschen
gebirgsjäger hütchen mit der weißen
feder daran in im bild steht und die
italiener motiviert sich impfen zu
lassen brauchen wir so was und warum
haben wir es nicht warum machen uns die
italiener jetzt was vor ich habe
den artikel meiner kollegin aus
brasilien gelesen wo eine szene
beschrieben wird wo also brasilianer die
eine ins quote von über 90 prozent haben
im café auf dem auf dem bildschirm ein
bericht aus deutschland sehen und es
einfach nicht glauben können und sagen
was ist da los und dann sagt der eine
zum anderen jahr die idioten dort lassen
sich nicht impfen
und ja wir ich denke
ich glaube aber nicht dass es weitere
appelle oder gebirgsjäger braucht weil
appelle hat es nun tatsächlich genug
gegeben und die autorität der
gebirgsjäger mag auch in deutschland ein
bisschen geringer sein ich denke schon
dass wir am ende an einer impfpflicht
nicht vorbeikommen werden und ich sage
ich ich bin aber auch eine gegnerin und
würde würden gebe auch zu dass ich da
meine meinung geändert habe und jetzt
trotz der massiven des massiven
eingriffs der den ich daran auch erkenne
und und den ich auch sehr problematisch
finde glaube dass wir daran nicht vorbei
kommen und zwar nicht weil es in der
jetzigen situation helfen würde dafür
ist es zu spät für diese vierte welle
wird eine impfpflicht kaum noch helfen
und jedenfalls auf keinen fall in den
nächsten wochen etwas bringen aber um
vorausschauend zu handeln
müssen wir uns darauf einstellen dass es
eine weitere welle geben wird und einen
weiteren herbst und einen weiteren
winter und deshalb glaube ich dass wir
die impfpflicht brauchen und dann bin
ich wieder bei robert habeck ich wollte
es vorhin schon sagen annalena baerbock
hatten im wahlkampf in einem dieser
stelle gesagt dass wir unbedingt eine
impfpflicht für die pflegeberufe
brauchen also genau in diesen
einrichtungen und hat das olaf scholz
auch noch in den schoß gelegt und sagte
die sozialdemokratin muss darüber reden
also es gibt einfach natürlich auch
erkenntnisse die kann und muss man auch
in der opposition glaube ich schon in
politik umsetzen und dann erst recht in
der regierung meine frage noch mal was
denken sie wird und muss nun durch
diesen krisenstab organisiert werden in
deutschland damit wir möglichst so viele
menschen wie möglich menschen mit
krisenstabs haben wieder gehört soll den
ablauf der kampagnen organisieren und
gucken fehlt es irgendwo und wenn es
irgendwo fehlt und es gibt noch
bundeswehreinheiten die unterstützen
können dann sorgte er dafür dass die
bundeswehreinheiten dahingehend
dass du nicht mit mir
der stab soll monitoren wie sich die
infektionszahlen entwickeln und das
täglich und nicht immer auf zuruf kurz
von der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
insofern sind dass instrumente die
eigentlich da bin ich ganz bei in längst
hätten eingeführt werden müssen die
instrumente sind allerdings nur die
schützen zur entscheidung
deswegen deswegen bin ich ich weiß nicht
ob mit absicht oder ob ich mich unklar
ausgedrückt habe worauf man eben ganz
missverstanden worden natürlich muss die
politik entscheiden ich würde nur
versuchen zu verstehen oder selber zu
erklären warum sie immer zu spät
entscheidet und wir versuchen jetzt
obwohl wir noch gar nicht in der
regierung sind genau das was gefordert
ist politische führung
präventiv für die zukunft rechtzeitig zu
treffen das hat nicht geklappt in der
vergangenheit aus gründen die ich
versucht habe zu beschreiben die
offensichtlich nicht gut genug
beschrieben wurden an der stelle und das
sind die instrumente und die werden dazu
führen im besten fall dass wir ohne
anlauf dann die richtigen adäquaten
entscheidungen treffen können ich war ja
sein er entweder gelingt es jetzt oder
pauschale entscheidung sind notwendig
und ich wollte ehrlich gesagt nur danach
fragen wie sehr sie sich unterstützt
fühlen durch ihre jetzigen
koalitionspartner also wie sehr sie die
fdp und die sozialdemokratie dazu
überreden müssen
fragezeichen aber darüber habt ihr
offensichtlich nicht viel gestritten
dann kann ich jetzt auch einen besingen
fragen herr wissen was wird aus einer
impfpflicht für die pflegeberufe ja nein
oder ja ich will eine sache noch mal
klarstellen wir hier ein falscher
eindruck entstanden ist vorhin
vielleicht bewusst oder erfahrung aus
versehen jetzt wurde der eindruck
erweckt dass das impfschutz gesetz dass
wir auf den weg gebracht dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz dass wir auf den
weg gebracht haben einfach nur maßnahmen
zurückgenommen hat das stimmt so nicht
wir haben also nur eine herrische geht
mir neue schärfere maßnahmen erlaubt und
wie die maßnahmen die wir zurückgenommen
haben die werden wir auch nicht wieder
einführen zum nicht zumindest nicht in
gänze beispielsweise die ausgangssperren
und das werden wir nicht tun haben
können weil das verfassungswidrig ist
das haben die gerichte bestätigt und mit
verfassungswidrigen maßnahmen können und
dürfen sie eine pandemie nicht bekämpfen
also wir müssen schon klarstellen es
gibt hier handlungsmöglichkeiten für die
länder die können morgen loslegen und es
ist überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar dass
diese maßnahmen nicht ausgeschöpft
werden das sind übrigens die
entscheidenden maßnahmen weil völlig zu
recht gesagt worden ist glaube sie haben
es gesagt voraus waren mit der impfung
können wir diese gegenwärtige situation
nicht lösen wenn wir die impfung herz
starten was sehr begrüßen würde ich rufe
alle auf das zu tun sich impfen zu
lassen brauchen wir mindestens sechs
wochen bis wir die die den schutz vor
der infektion haben dann haben wir aber
das problem dieses winters nicht gelöst
die impfpflicht kann man diskutieren
werden dass auch verfassungsrechtlich
sorgfältig prüfen und wir sind bereit zu
jedem gespräch was hilft maßnahmen
anzuordnen die verfassungskonform sind
diese pandemie bekämpfen ich finde das
auch gut man braucht man sagt sie war
anderer meinung ändert ihre mal ich
finde das alles in ordnung das ist
völlig in ordnung in einer solchen
situation aber sich vor zu machen mit
einer impfpflicht könne man das problem
des dezembers 2021 lösen ist falsch hat
aber noch nie eine bank jetzt ständig
erweckt bei der ist nicht nur die frage
beantworten der impfpflicht er hängt die
frage zusammen wie kommen wir durch den
winter nächstes jahr 2022 und jetzt
kommen wir durch diesen winter nur dann
gut wenn wir die maßnahmen die wir jetzt
haben kontakt beschränkungen voll
ausschöpfen wir müssen handeln und
schnell muss ja eben aber es gibt auch
keinen zusammenhang lassen sie mich den
satz noch zu ende führen damit das auch
mal klar gesagt ist es gibt keinen
zusammenhang zwischen der änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes unter jetzt den
jetzigen infektionszahlen den gibt es
nicht und deswegen noch in zwei kriegen
und deswegen geben es gibt allerdings
verändert müssen und dass man deswegen
muss man sagen es sind heute noch viele
möglichkeiten zu handeln und natürlich
braucht man auch so ein krisenstab dass
es denen noch nicht gibt finde ich
empörend ich glaube dass wir den
dringend brauchen und es ist ja auch ein
gutes zeichen dass die bundeswehr in ihn
jetzt auch einführt ich hatte so ein
vorschlag ich hatte sie dennoch nach der
impfpflicht für die pflegeberufe also
für einzelne einrichtungen gefragt ist
die fdp mittlerweile dafür ja ja wir
halten das für sinnvoll einrichtungs
bezogen es macht ja keinen sinn einzelne
berufsgruppen wenn ich jetzt das
pflegepersonal impfe und die
reinigungskräfte gehen dann durch das
pflegezimmer und sie nicht geimpft haben
wir machte ihr habt doch das ist ja auch
eine neue debatte wird die einrichtungs
bezogene früher hatte man immer nur
gesagt das pflegepersonal soll geimpft
werden das macht alleine auch keinen
sinn aber natürlich müssen wir all diese
maßnahmen müssen wir
nutzen denn es darf nicht sein dass der
staat alle möglichkeiten auf der
grundlage des grundgesetzes nicht
ausschöpft um diese pandemie zu bekommen
sie haben noch am 18.11 gesagt nein eine
impfpflicht wird es mit der fdp nicht
geben weder für die gesamte bevölkerung
noch in bestimmten berufen jetzt ist
diese position der fdp auch ein bisschen
klüger sie sagen pflege bezogen ist das
völlig in ordnung oder die einrichtungs
bezogen und wies einrichtungs bis zur
entschuldigung ich habe irgendwann
personengruppen bezogen ich glaube
personengruppen bezogen ist es mit am
schwierigsten verfassungsrechtlich
einrichtungs bezogen es ist warm und
damit wollte das mit dem statement nicht
deutlich machen klammer auf aber eine
einrichtung bezogene wäre für uns in
ordnung sie wollten deutlich machen es
wird mit uns keine impfpflicht geben
egal wie sie aussieht und das war eine
totale fehleinschätzung diese
impfpflicht für pflegeeinrichtung und
meiner meinung nach auch für kitas und
grundschulen müsste ist schon sechs bis
acht wochen ist liegt die damit diese
äußerungen im zusammenhang mit der
äußerung des bundesgesundheitsministers
getätigt dass ich hingestellt hatte
elfter und hat gesagt ja ich hatte diese
noch ich hatte ich bin davon ausgegangen
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister einen
guten überblick hat und sagt wir können
die epidemische notlage beenden dann
fragt man mich zwei wochen später wollen
sie eine allgemeine impfpflicht in
deutschland dass das ist ja nicht eine
impfpflicht ist ein schwerwiegender
grundrechtseingriff der muss sorgfältig
geprüft werde und er kann wahrscheinlich
auch nach allen abläufen nicht vor dem
ersten treffen will aber nicht ein thema
zur pflicht auch dazu sagen man muss
natürlich auch realistisch sein so etwas
durchzusetzen und zu kontrollieren ist
nicht trivial das wäre jetzt meine frage
an und wenn die gegenwärtige situation
hatten haben dass wir das boostern was
ja eine sofortige verbesserung bringt im
vergleich zur übrigen zuerst impfung die
sechs wochen dauert bis man im griff
schutz ist das buch dann ja das so dass
das was sofort wirkt da muss man sagen
wir haben jetzt im augenblick ja
offensichtlich engpässe weil die
bundesregierung die amtierende
bundesregierung nicht ausreichend
impfstoff beschafft hat also wir reden
zum teil auch an den konkreten lösungen
den konkreten gerade über das boostern
geredet und ich habe sie gerade nach der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
gefragt es ist gut dass sie darauf
hinweisen dass die auch sanktioniert
werden muss wie weit würden sie gehen
also immer auch eine frage der kontrolle
bei diesem ganzen corona maßnahmen über
die ganze zeit diskutiert haben in den
letzten jahren wurde immer wieder der
eindruck erweckt als könne der staat die
dinge die da anordnet auch am ende
durchsetzen und controlling katalog
macht man das das wird man sehen das ist
eine nicht triviale
verfassungsrechtliche frage dieser solle
geprüft werden muss weil niemand soll
sich für etwas vormachen mit
verfassungswidrigen entscheidungen mit
man am ende nur eine bauchlandung
erleiden wir haben das bei den
ausgangssperren gesehen die wollte herr
söder erst als wichtigstes instrument
zur pandemie bekämpfung haben als die
gerichte ihn eines besseren belehrt habe
erklärte er plötzlich so was könne weg
das brauche man nicht so kann man nicht
mit dem mit grundrechten umgehen es gibt
ein buntes meinungsbild auch bei der cdu
herr röttgen einrichtungs bezogen die
impfpflicht ja oder nein da haben auch
sie sich bewegt oder sagen sie ja also
zunächst mal darf ich einen punkt haben
wir sagen es fehlt am impfstoff wir
haben in deutschland kein mangel an
impfstoff weil wir für impfen werben
sollten wir keine verunsicherung stiften
es fehlt nicht an impfstoff wir haben
impfstoff vorhanden um die impfungen die
versicherung funktioniert nicht den
menschen reden ist ja
wirklich nicht schlecht wir so ist es
aber nicht am impfstoff genau so ist es
an dem fehlt ist nicht wenn sie das
alles verfassungsrechtlich prüfen ist
das angemessen nur da sie ja jetzt
selber sagen einrichtungs bezogen sind
sie für die impfpflicht dann haben sie
die frage ja bestimmt dann auch schon
verfassungsrechtlich geprüft also ist
die prüfung ja schon abgeschlossen und
können sie diese meinung ja nicht haben
ich bin seit längerer zeit aber
vielleicht habe ich mich dann auch
irgendwann mal dahin bewegt aber ich bin
seit längerer zeit dafür habe das auch
öffentlich geäußert vor monaten schon da
habe ich mich für eine impfpflicht für
ich habe aber damals auch nicht so genau
differenzieren ihr habt das pflege
berufen so dass wohl damals er sprach
gebraucht aber es ist richtiger für das
personal in einrichtungen die mit
besonders gefährdeten menschen zu tun
haben ich habe auch immer die kitas dazu
gezählt zum beispiel krankenhäuser
pflegeeinrichtungen ausgesprochen
längerer zeit schon und das die
allgemeine impfpflicht anbelangt da
sagen ja wissen ja auch alles auch eine
frage der logik das ist zählt nicht zu
den akuten maßnahmen jetzt ich bin aber
dafür dass wir diese maßnahme jetzt
prüfen vor allen dingen
verfassungsrechtlich auch in der art wie
man sie einführen will auch was ist die
folge wenn man die pflicht nicht befolgt
um dann nach dieser welle vorbereitet zu
sein um endlich die nächste welle dann
abwenden zu können und durch bessere
maßnahmen also wir prüfen wir nähern uns
an wir verschieben manches urteil aber
irgendwann wird man um ein jahr nicht
mehr hinbekommen das gleiche mit anderen
entscheidungen auch jetzt wird gesagt
impfpflicht hilft aktuell akut nicht
brauchen wir jetzt erstmal nicht machen
jetzt kümmern wir uns um die akute
krisenbekämpfung vor den european open
war früher sinken dann die
infektionszahlen die leute wittern
morgenluft dann wird gesagt ja eine
allgemeine impfpflicht die können wir
jetzt in dieser politischen und gunnar
war gar nicht einfach dafür gibt's ja
gar keine gesellschaftliche mehrheit und
dann kommt wieder der herbst und dann
wird man wieder feststellen und fünfte
welle und das ist genau das gleiche wie
mit 2g zweig dürfen wir nicht machen
zweig spaltet die gesellschaft zweig
brauchen wir im moment nicht die lage
ist gut aber maxi lage nicht mehr gut
wir führen 2 g ein und stellen aber fest
in der lage in der wir uns befinden
reich zweig nicht mehr und das ist
einfach ein politischer zyklus der muss
durchbrochen werden und zwar jetzt ja
nicht in vier wochen oder in sechs
wochen oder im netz aber in dem sie
gerade prognostizieren dass er nicht
gebrochen wird dieser zugriff
beteiligen sich ja daran dass es so
bleibt wie es ist das macht doch keinen
sinn jetzt zu übersehen dass wir eine
ernsthafte debatte neu darüber haben
eine allgemeine impfpflicht einzuführen
ich würde mal sagen der allgemeine
meinung sicher und der allgemeine
meinung stand war das ist zu weit gehen
dieser meinung war ich auch und ich
glaube wir sehen wir sehen jetzt die
situation dass die die argumente die
dagegen gesprochen haben angesichts der
lage keinen bestand haben also warum man
das jetzt schon perspektivisch wieder
schlecht redet das verstehe ich wirklich
erleichtert bin ich ja
ich habe gesagt ich habe gesagt was der
initiative sind weg das tue ich habe das
modell beschrieben nachdem
und wo vieles dafür spricht dass es sich
wiederholt wenn ich jetzt dagegen und
gearbeitet
würde ich würde doch jetzt nicht
sie haben es dargestellt als wäre ich
der meinung dass das jetzt so laufen
soll aber dann der hinweis darauf dass
der hinweis darauf dass gummersbach
leider total recht hat ist doch dass
sich der künftige kanzler in dieser
frage nicht positioniert sondern genau
sagt ich warte jetzt mal ab olaf scholz
hat keine position zu der frage ob es
eine impfpflicht braucht oder nicht
sondern er sagt es ist gut dass es diese
debatte gibt und das ist genau die
fatale taktik die frau aus bach in dem
moment beschrieben hat und dass das ist
so eine art des führer der führung die
ich befürchte da jetzt zusehen leading
vom behind die aber einfach
leading zu spät bedeutet in dieser
pandemie und und nicht funktionieren
wird sondern immer wieder in diesem
teufelskreis
wir werden in der zwischenzeit habe ich
einen wirtschaftsminister erleben der
unternehmern und unternehmen sagen muss
dass sie auch ihre geschäfte wieder
schließen wollen und sollen oder möchten
sie eben das unbedingt vermeiden und
würde es dann wieder corona helfen geben
unterstützungen geben für firmen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen schneller
als das früher der fall war was tut der
wirtschaftsminister
wenn das wieder so kommt dann wird das
unternehmenshilfen geben wie es gab das
ist doch völlig logisch dass ist
eingespielt und dann kann man darauf
setzen und hoffen dass wieder die
gleiche decke zyklus passiert ein paar
unternehmen werden es nicht schaffen die
meisten werden überstehen trotzdem die
leute unzufrieden also das ist das ist
ja klar
und da kann man natürlich auch
also diese notfallpläne werden sie dann
logischerweise genauso schmieden noch
sind sie überzeugt davon dass man
geschäfte offen lassen kann und dass man
da bin ich nicht von überzeugt von das
habe ich versucht deutlich zu machen und
ähnlich den zyklus zu beschreiben wir
haben bisher überhaupt gar keinen grund
von irgendwas überzeugt zu sein weil
immer alles zu spät oder gar nicht
gewirkt hat das müssen wir zur kenntnis
nehmen obwohl die maßnahmen eigentlich
da sind werden sie von den ländern
gespielt umgesetzt werden die
politischen entscheidungen zu spät
getroffen werden die statistiken die
frage war die welle glauben sie ja in
das wir versuchen ist ich muss man fast
sagen noch einmal aber das könnte der
unterschied sein zur letzten regierung
indem man es zu einem alltagsgeschäft
macht in dem man täglich schaut
funktioniert ist nicht wieder 14 tage
vergisst dass wir eine pandemie haben
die zahlen sind ja da und die
krankenhäuser sind voll deswegen
lassen sie sich ganz kurz einmal gesagt
wir kriegen die reds eingerichtet wird
ist gebaut nach dem modell 2015
flüchtlingskrise da war ich damals
minister ich habe das mit verfolgt da
gab es ein tägliches bund-länder-treffen
ein tägliches bund länder treffen wo
geguckt wird was braucht es an
unterkünften wie sind die leute verteilt
wie ist die sicherheitslage und so
weiter und sofort alles was damals
gemacht wurde wurde im täglichen doing
gemacht die korona pandemie ist ja
durchaus vergleichbar sie ist die
überforderte am anfang jedes wissen und
die institution und vieles hat nicht
geklappt das ist das ist ja
operationelles doing und wenn der da ist
dann hat man zumindest eine chance nicht
wieder in dieses strukturelle scheitern
reinzulaufen die idee dahinter ist dass
man nicht den eindruck erweckt alle
können sich ausruhen die politik
entscheidet dann zwei monatsweise von
oben herab so jetzt machen wir was dicht
und was nicht sondern wir stehen hier
als gesellschaft davor diese pandemie
gemeinsam zu bekämpfen täglich kümmert
man sich darum täglich gibt es auch
erfolgs oder misserfolgs meldung
umso dieses die diese lässigkeit die es
irgendwie immer wenn es halbwegs gut
läuft gegen jede erkenntnis zu
durchbrechen das ist die idee dahinter
das ist die idee der den
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht immer
gleich oder nicht zu warten bis es
eskaliert und dann macht man es dich
dann wartet man wieder bis die kurve
untergegangen ist und dass ich wieder
laufen dann macht man sie wieder dicht
sondern ist dauerhaft zu bekämpfen und
das könnte auch vielleicht dazu führen
dass wir eine höhere impfraten bekommen
und weil auch da ist ja die der eindruck
die da oben wollen dass ich mich impfen
lasse für einen teil der bevölkerung
also ich verstehe ist nicht weil ich wir
sehen ja wie gefährlich die krankheit
ist aber ein teil der menschen denkt
wenn ich mich nicht impfen lasse wieder
setzte ich mich diese bevormundung von
da oben das ist doch eher so dass und
wie heißen für im juni begann habe und
das ist einfach überhaupt da